I am cute I'm Chris reinecker hey I'm
Joyce hey I'm destiny and today we're
gonna be taste testing chicken nuggets
allegedly how long have you loved
chicken nuggets
I think that's been like a thing in my
life you know it seems like a young boy
I was a stand of chicken nuggets as a
child now that I'm adult and I know
better
can't do it I physically cannot consume
I eat chicken as a little honey actually
me too yeah I'm honey I'm a honey Dipper
for sure
I'm not a big mustard usual no no no I
used to buy chicken nuggets and dip them
in honey a hundred percent I think
chicken nuggets are cute pruin I'm drunk
oh but in my day-to-day life I've always
been a beef pretty confident I'm not
going to like these but they're paying
me to do it these claim to be the best
chicken nuggets in the world but they're
also not chicken they're vegan they're
vegan I don't buy it already I haven't
tasted yeah
but I'm skeptical I'm smelling these and
everyone's like oh this smells so good
it smells like vegan chicken at least
have twice the amount of protein as in
regular chicken okay that's hard to
believe right geez what does that mean
it feels like a regular chicken nugget
I'm gonna be honest these aren't hot it
smell like chicken nuggets they're
shaped like goldfish okay that's a
little unusual looking okay you know I'm
gonna go for it just regular regular
regular oh just your entire straight no
sauce sweet yeah let's let's go no sauce
and then because the sauce will make you
start to think yeah yeah yeah no we
can't do that
[Music]
I'm not mad at it it tastes like a
chicken nugget very dry very dry the
best chicken nuggets in the world that's
a stretch is it okay sure
like is it a nice replacement for it
like meat if you don't eat meat the
aftertaste is good the aftertaste is
very good tasty there is something out
there for everybody hmm
this isn't for me everyone has their own
ministry everyone has gone past within
God's light and this is not the path but
I will say if I was forced to eat a
chicken nugget as my last meal I would
ask for a vegan chicken nugget okay bad
buy so we're just not like - it needs
the outside needs a little crunch
maybe but I might just because it's not
hot the crust was perfect oh that
crispness of it but the inside doesn't
peel you know the way peels yeah a
little more moister mm-hmm you might be
on it the inside is like like tuna like
and that's yeah that's not chicken
nugget is it but it actually tastes
pretty good
I can't learn like the taste it's like
you can keep eating them well apparently
these are engineered vegan chicken
nuggets that are always being upgraded
there is oh there's always new
you're almost there everybody at the
company is under 30 I think that's a
good thing I've experienced I think
maybe with more experience we might get
my nuggets I'm gonna disagree
I'd like that they're young I like
saying young people do cool I was a bit
of a skeptic originally but now that
I've had a few several I'm not mad at it
I would take these over regular chicken
lettuce absolutely well that's not gonna
I mean I'm not gonna right now look I
was a hater at the beginning but ever
its ever since I got them you know like
look they're doing their best I'm like
then this is pretty good guy I'm willing
to grow with you you know I'm saying I
live in the light and the truth and I
know vegan it's like hunting cute like
Instagram of all my green smooth
like hashtag bliss but I'm still an
island go i I love meat I've gone on
quite a journey because I started very
skeptical and I am being like alright
okay I got it
I'm happy I came to this video and try
it I am coming out better a better
person than when I came in but I would
not search this out in the food so is
this how you usually chicken menu
absolutely no making them not with any
of these Nuggets but actually they're
pretty good cuz if you've been noticing
I've been going
[Music]